so I want to tell you guys that I passed
a sheet of paper before coming here to
people in the crowd to ask what type of
questions I would I could ask you and
what I ended up getting was only names
of songs
truly it's amazing the list of
accomplishments that you guys have as a
band I don't think that either you guys
or any other band in the world could
have taught us of so many
accomplishments and I'm just going to
name a few Jose Antonio didn't mention
the group has earned 14 nomination for a
traditional Grammy and three times for a
Latin Grammy in total you guys have won
six Grammy Awards a lot one for that is
I want to convey you've registered
global sales that exceed 32 million
units you've recorded more than 55
albums that have received platinum and
called records the band has appeared in
more than 14 films in Mexico it de los
Tigres del Norte exhibit corrido
sinfronteras
travels around the country with the
smithsonian institute los Tigres del
Norte Foundation supports the
preservation of Mexican and Mexican
American folk music with the university
of california los angeles and los Tigres
del norte incorporated has more than 300
million dollars in revenue through
selling products in the hispanic market
so this is just amazing what drives you
guys to continue and how do you guys
keep healthy and motivated with this
amount of hard work people
all this inspiration comes from stories
that we heard the stories that we live
in it a society the way we we see things
on the street how how we appreciate what
we do how the people give us so much
ways to to put happiness in our lives in
one way in let's drive us to to continue
every day to get new songs new
inspiration new ways to communicate new
words that we learn every day from from
people and that's what it makes us to
believe that we can do solve so many
things but these five people this right
here when we got together to do
something we got to think very clearly
what we want to talk about stories from
the real life that's the main concern
operas not fictitious stories get the
real story and to put it in a song
inspiration good things bad things but
we learn from that and that's quality to
still attend Northey has been doing
through the years a lot of the people in
the crowd are people who are starting
business and are gonna come out of here
to work very hard and struggle with that
balance between work and family and
spending time for themselves you guys
two or 44 weeks a year so how do you how
do you guys have that balance I guess
many people know that
you guys are all family four siblings
and one cause in Oscar so how do you
find that balance between work and
family I'm gonna give you the microphone
to her now because he's can I take it
he's kicking me Frankie I want to talk
okay
first guy to everybody the rest say hi
to the people hola it's the first I
think he will I think he was very
embarrassed to sing not to talk via no
control if I see La Porta [ __ ] for you
guys then talk about business I think my
business to see La Porta [ __ ]
okay so let's be serious now George okay
you know it's very it's very very
important for us that the they consider
us to be here talking to their because
since we were little I was I was the
youngest of the time we're just
aggressive started it how many years I
was eight
now I'm only 28 and I was the youngest
one at a time and and talking about how
important is the family roots and how
the family waiting for all this to isn't
here the way you parents put the teens
in you here you know you had to study
you had to be somebody you had to do
this you have to do because you're going
to struggle when you get old and then
you know you don't want to be selling
tacos to working a mock dance which is
like that so in those days there was no
McDonald's in our hometown not so our
parents really struggle to give us you
know ii ii ii ii dress we used to be in
our hometown where like in 68 we decide
to continue that stay because our father
got sick an operation and it was so much
money at the time he cost around 100
thousand pesos there was a lot of money
you know we didn't we didn't have a way
to for him to get operation and that's
how your day was the the oldest at the
time but he was little at the time so
was
so he decide for us to to start a plane
and I think that the necessity the way
that we start los Tigres it was because
there because we need money to support
our family and we are family or 11 at
the time we would family Tamika Lewis
wasn't born yet was born I was born like
15 years ago so I think I think it's
very very important you know that that
when you family raise you the way you
family when you need when you listen to
your parents the necessities that you
have each day you know especially when
you come for a role little hometown in
Mexico I think it's even harder because
not everyone and not everybody has the
opportunity to worry school you know
nobody if you don't have in Mexico at
those days when we were little you know
not too many kids here they pretended to
go even to the next big town to to go to
school so your Chi was the only one that
guessed they pretended to hold a
preparatory after their de la primera
and I only went to la primera in Mexico
but I went to high school here and in
San Jose and I think we we always think
that occasion is that is the the first
the first thing to have success in your
life even even if I didn't go to school
but I think going back to the family the
rules that we have in our minds know
that the where our parents talked to us
that we were educated at in this where
this white would to doesn't know they're
here right now I am phanie i I I'm gonna
be 29 July 22nd so I do 22nd and you
so I wanna I wanna give you my other
that we can see me gifts 21st and 22nd
okay the man the one has almost 40 years
of history and talking about business
many companies failed to renew
themselves to newer to newer generations
and I think you have been able to
continue to attract younger audiences to
your music how do you accomplish that
you do you get feedback from your
audience how is it that that process
works well we have the opportunity to be
our stage as our office we we can see a
lot of stuff from the stage I can see
the way people are approach to them you
can see when when people don't like one
song and then you have to think you have
to look you have to analyze what's real
happen we have disappearance we can be
working around the stage but I'm looking
and I'm seeing and I feeling and our
music is all the music is through the
skin this if your skin don't react to
you when you sing a song and you see the
public is not getting back to you
something's wrong
and probably the story that you're
trying to tell people then I believe in
you
and when that happen we have to make
changes and the songs we have to
reinvent yourself the way how you
communicate how you wanna say that
exactly world so they can people move to
the straight to us and as when you
prepare a song in the studio and then
you get the song those lyrics
you gotta think first not the way the
compositor bring you the song and you
have to fix it up you have to
this is the piece of meat and this meat
you have to cook it right and you have
to you have to given the right taste for
the people then it's very hard to do it
because sometimes people that have
different way flavors so they can taste
before they comparing you with that
and that sample that does example is
that I given you today is because we
live that life every day every night
when we perform we have to have to see
we have to have the feeling if when you
lose that feeling with the with you
people in our case you losing everything
some clients some people that really
like your music your fans and then you
got a problem in the future and you you
you get in your John you you grow up you
go on you state your life your
generations this is the four generation
that you've we we've been singing for
them and you have to take a look of this
young people in I can you know have the
impression what you like what you don't
like what what it can be done so please
you guys in one way and then we're going
in life
step by step growing up what I like
yesterday probably don't like today and
tomorrow is gonna be something that I
will change for whoever we are one my
life tomorrow and that change your life
little bit and you have to learn from
there and when you're learning you get
it you're gonna accomplish in the future
and be always been thinking today but
tomorrow to please you
fans need new ways to communicate with
the songs in our case you guys talked
about that specific radical change that
has passed through these 40 years in
which you guys said we have to change in
this aspect or in this other aspect to
tailor they the younger generation well
hello how are you well being the jungus
I I can see you know I grew up listening
to law students I was a fan of those
Tigres before being here you know I was
born many years after they started and I
remember as metal is calm at the least
the promos occurring I'm the I'm the I'm
the youngest brother there's no other
brothers so I don't think that's gonna
be enough for me yeah like I say I grew
up listening to los Tigres and I know
that los Tigres have been changing along
with the people along with the with the
vocabulary people uses on the street
every day that's what is keeping us on
the ID of the public on their ears you
know we try every year when we record
because we require every year to use the
vocabulary people uses on the street to
learn about the problems because even
though problems are similar they change
a little bit because times times have
changed and I think that that's one of
the the main things that most eaters
have done and also we are involved in
the community not only here where we
live with difference I'm saying we're
very involved with our Latin community
and opener also in Mexico we are we know
the problems we know the needs over
people people comes to us and tell us
what is it that they're leaving at the
moment what is it I would like to hear
from us and we we really listen
to the way they speak to us a way they
project their emotions to us that's very
important and I think we we are through
the years we have learned that if we're
seeing their stories and realities we're
gonna be here you know it's it's it's as
easy as that but it's also very
difficult because you need to make
people believe in you we have an
advantage we're four singers in each of
us have a different personality and a
different way to approach the fans of
los Tigres and that's why you know two
generations we are we are here and
people come to see us and to listen to
our songs but not only to a querido not
only to a ballad you know they would
like to hear a diversity of songs and we
have there are four different singers
that can give people that diversity and
and that's that's something that that
people likes they have a different a
different perspective and a different
point of view coming from us you know
it's so as long as we keep on listening
to the people we're gonna be here thank
you
changing a little bit topics one of the
big problems you usually talk about in
your songs is immigration
you left Ross Amerada McCrory toes in a
law in 1968 coming north to find a
better future for your family can you
talk a little bit more about the
challenges that you have got as
immigrants trying to make it work in the
United States after you you wanna speak
to a lady you know much about this story
you know because you guys came in listen
I so you guys know better about you know
immigrant people then they're not
because at those times it was harder
than than today or to get in and us so
I'm gonna let your show talk about that
but the issue from the a the immigration
it's been years
years three years we've been sinking
stories we've been singing we've been
getting the the real story from books
from some Spain when this land from
California Utah Nevada Arizona Texas a
bit used to belong to Mexico so we we
the first song that we recorded the
immigrant issue it was a song they
called viva los mahalos and it was the
story when we recorded we we never
thought that they would have that strong
response to the to the group and with
that with their in 1973 I believe and
the the people when when we came out to
the stage and sing the song we have
different feelings from people some of
them they get happy some they cry and
someday they stir be quiet and go down
the
I start thinking and that's when we find
out that there's something the community
need a boys he needs somebody to tell
the stories the community people was
said it was something that make you
happy but also when they listen this
story about this song they feel pride
what they listened to what they came and
we I find out through the years think in
different different stories I can tell
you a lot of them they probably you not
related to him but we sing up amnesty
and end of the years also for from
storage that we find out through the
government that they give him permit to
be legal and this and some other they
they room they don't care too much about
it and they still come illegal and those
stories we tell them but when when this
stories came out more as stronger it was
start to believe what we were singing
what we saying what we we really want to
tell my story
a nanny story all the groupie story and
Yuri story and everybody has a related
family in Mexico cousin uncle story you
mom your father
the way they came from your country not
only from Mexico different countries in
through the years the immigration issue
from Asus it's been very strong because
we have the opportunity to get his tours
from a different countries we got a
story very strong it calls services
mojado
it was the story from the Salvadorian
and then we will find out that the
community from the Salvador they believe
the law stated in order to be long
to them and in the latter another ways
the way we we seen these stories and
then we start missing those countries
like Salvador Nicaragua Honduras
Guatemala and all these people get
related to really stories through the
years and the migration issues is one of
the most important issue they lost a
little northagen can get into them
because we they all these people they
come to this country or we came to this
country we live in the dark for so many
years and still and so dark as as a
curtain and here because our government
from Mexico we don't have no laws to
help us to survive you have long United
States but we don't belong here in the
because we are illegal we don't have the
rise the probably the humours rise and
probably people that's already legal
it's very simple II can ignore this but
people they there is not legal is live
in the dark darlings and then what he
make more problems to the north after
years and years and years singing and
telling these stories really stories
through the years and as the through the
years Mexico has economically it was the
first division from all these illegal
people that works and all legal people
they work Singh sent money to Mexico it
was the first division in our country
and as some something they they made me
feel proud but also our government
it's not with us and as very sad for us
because it's very we are in between we
always been behind the curtains and it's
very sad and that what amazed me and my
brothers to believe that we have to keep
singing these stories
life is stories stories the touch of
hearts but only the true now fictitious
and that's what he makes difference
between our community and you here
presents the body make him better humans
better understanding and better prepare
for the future
and to help community so we can together
get what we want we want those curtains
out we want to recognize us in Mexico
and in other countries whatever country
we coming from that we're doing
something that we left of the country
but for a reason because whatever
reasons we laugh in Mexico because
economically because whatever it is
we're doing something right here we are
doing for the community and for our
Mexico Mexican people they stay there
and send some money for them to keep
living the way we wanted to daily they
can live better and strive we came a
distal reason that we came here from and
as that reason that were Greece has more
importance on what whatever we do
because we believe what we're doing and
as what he drives us to be a better
understanding and better person with
everybody but the child with the
youngers whether all people always trip
everybody right and as this looks
thicker than Norte we are we always do
try to do the best each of us can give
what we got we try to give understanding
and love that's quite the only thing
that we can offer in our songs and our
and our personalities stay the way we
are we are made we are absolutely stay
away immigrant rights in the United
States yet Mexico or Latin American
countries have so many challenges
nowadays there are countless call it
corruption call it drug trafficking
which are the topics you consider to
talk about in the future and what do you
think it is important to to talk about
in society what we can we can I think
the the community haves a huge problem
and drugs whose problem in prostitution
and his problems mmm and and the main
enemy immigration side I think the more
issue that we that we can get into is
the separation of the jungus term child
is born and emigration goes and take
away the father and mother and they live
in this country alone
they put her in the different homes
federal homes that's one of those issues
that that we that we I think it's one of
the most important for the future of
generation of the new generations that
come in the future and to talk about
there is very important in our songs but
also do something about it is more
important
we just term it was invited in and
Washington DC
two months ago was disgusting but the
Congress and you know and Washington
about that issue that's very important
and they bring us that issue so we can
make commercials so we can tell the
people you know sometimes we have to
deny ourselves more so we can not fail
and that issue that's very important and
every one of those stories that I will
prepare in this as to to tell the story
correctly and there's so many things
that we're going to that we wanted to
think about it but I think first what is
first I don't want to open the questions
to a forum before asking you guys a
little bit about business in general you
you have revenues of 300 million dollars
per per year which is just an
astonishing number for any any any type
of company you would be on the top of of
the Mexican largest companies with that
number and I'd like to ask you most
successful these most successful music
groups are not famous for being wise
managers of their money and you have
contradicted this belief you are cashew
servers savers but you are also very
successful investors in the Hispanic
market can you talk a little bit about
the businesses that you have done and
what has driven you guys to do them
I think is is it's a little complicated
to attack and a few minutes about that
because I think you have a report there
to talk about that some more money I
think that that came in a magazine from
Mexico like a few years ago right but I
think the information that they given
and there is the order revenues you know
when we play that as amended as well as
tigress make you know this this is the
the URL up all the concerts
I think this that's how he he there the
writer wrote that I think it was a
confusion of him you know they even have
to call us and in a Serb you know the he
that's how he did it you know he he set
up all the concerts nobody gave him the
amount of the concert you know you know
how much lost English are but he by
going to concerts I think he figured out
was in the people there and they saw a
figure it out in the several of the
records but it doesn't mean you know
spirit soul to the two million already
that doesn't mean the most aggressive
the they're there all the money was
follows tigress you know what I mean is
I put it two million
the company has most of the money
analysts agree so so and then and then
and and the density the same thing you
know the concept is the same thing you
know you can help Anita some people
whether does I mean they're all the
revenue is los Tigres money you know
lost irreligious you get paid to where I
think but an industry of the of the of
the of the the concerts it is a lot of
money you know the the figure is about
right you know 300 million a year in
concerts but there are some in the
mysterious gated 300 million so so I
wish you know
well I probably haven is never giving
classes so I did I think this does the
information you know that that you have
in there because other center we can
cause us problems because there are
people especially things the way they
are now you know the personal Mexico
with so many things going we're wrong
with the violence you know with people
getting getting conversations or
Quattro's in English kidnaps you know
that that put us in the anticipation to
because because people really thinks you
know the deleterious gave all that money
you know I repeated again it is a lot of
money in their business but but not all
the money's ours you know is like huge
little present huge little present
okay so so I think I think you know this
this this kind of uh we can talk about
it later and the back would stage me in
you so IIIi want to make it clear you
know because because he's he likes
misleading information because the
person he may have to call back and say
you know because we were a lawyer to
Aaron you know to because there was they
was produced an Indian dangerous to
because there's a lot of money to say
let's make all the money when it's not
correct you know it's not it's not true
you know honestly you know you know
we've been working so hard for so many
years but it's not the industries he's
not lost egrets you know those theories
record for a comp or a record company
who still work for for a promotion in a
concert company so so those are the ones
they made the money is really you know
yes what other type of businesses are
you guys engaged on well we are involved
in the radio stations we are involved in
and radio business we are involved in
the dance halls in different different
states of the United States we see here
and the Euro business with we are
involve and digital digital digital
power digital and we are involved with
the withouts revenues that the group it
dint into it before and now as a new new
[Music]
technology we are involved companies
that that we are given our well our name
and we are working together we are we
have a little another business with
Universal and we are moving little by
little we owned a publishing company to
do this when a division company that all
the songs that will record or somebody
if we have ideas they can come to us and
we we can down we will help them out to
to get idea better and we have we trying
to put our in the future school music to
school they will want to the small
children's to start learning more music
and that's the feature plus degrees we
have some venues to you nose holes to so
so now I'm saying there that way you
know where the 300 comes because and
there is not personal questions only
business questions say your name and
where you're from and please be loud in
order for everyone to hear back there
hey I'm from Spain thank you very much
for coming which Agra first rocky my
question is about I would like to hear a
little bit your point of view about the
Internet and the music because from one
hand you can sell your songs in iTunes I
check that you have a lot of music over
there but in the other hand it can hurt
your revenues because people are sharing
music for free
so if you could talk a little bit about
this I would be Thanks
well the internet especially the company
use you just mentioned is we have very
huge amount of money and the way they're
doing business they we don't we not
paying back to the glory of this and
royalties to the group I believe the
last check them what's giving me a
document about three weeks ago uncle a
desirous of it know Cyrano same
community Rosa
it was you you're talking about the
heats over music and the one day they
play down 18 million in three months
18 millions downloads and three months
money that we don't we don't have your
royalties pay now we are we have we
belong to this company that we know
exactly who has the songs who put it
down
so we we want to do something about that
and that's the Internet has been I think
it's been very very successful Frank
what what they doing and then their own
business but I think a lot of people a
lot of artists and a lot of artists and
compositors and editorials they Nigerian
they share correctly and that's gonna be
always been a big big problem for the
music industry not only for us for
everybody
it that is there is no for every country
every language we've been we've been hit
very hard by them the people they don't
pay the royalties it's companies you
know the the the Internet in like los
Tigres kids the reporter we got a few
weeks ago 18 million hits you know done
loss even though it's a free but where
they made a money is with the publicity
that they put around that videos in
order on our music so this this the
sponsors this what you do and all those
websites made the money so this there we
are right now you know that what we're
trying to do I think we we working with
this company now they're the I think we
want to be the first Hispanic oh that
was Latino artists you know that is
going to try to get clear with with all
this website especially with you to you
know because 18 minutes and three months
without we're at
you know this this kind of safe for
everybody not only for the students but
even and there and for the American
artist you know they going through the
same thing you know maybe I feel them
they already also with with with
probably with you to go with West Side
wireless theorists are gonna be the
first Mexicano group you know that is
gonna run into that with you too I hope
by next we were here that set up
tomorrow night can I add something to
that before going on that I think that
also you know it has a economic impact
on our societies is also affecting us
because like we have talked about our
people our market it's it's the people
that you know the the worker people that
people that works in in the kitchen and
you know and not everybody at their
homes have us as a computer you know and
even though there's another downloads of
our music there's a lot of people that
cannot get our music in an iPad on a
soon on their blackberries because they
don't have the opportunity to have those
things so but also they don't have the
money to go and buy a CD so it's a
economy it's affecting us in both ways
we are gonna work hard to go and on the
internet and you know get royalties for
all those downloads that are being there
but also we're gonna keep on working
hard to give that people our music so
they can so they can have the
opportunity to listen to our music and
that's where we have to work together
not only los Tigres but also that
that or they're artists in the industry
you know and that's a very important I
think that I wanted to mention because
the way things are right now it's it's
really affecting our people where we're
coming from and that's something that it
really worries us hi thanks for coming
my name is Ryan Prowse I'm from Utah or
Tjuta commonly as decent you do that um
you know unfortunately I've never had
the opportunity to hear you sing I've
never heard any of your music I was
hoping you could change that for me is
there any possible way you could do an
acapella number for us right there on
the stage
[Music]
you know you know there every time they
were one is single with the warm up in
an hour so we'll be back in an hour
is this true
you know it's like it let the players
you know they had to warm up before they
where they feel so way too warm are the
boys at least for 15 minutes we warm up
in front of them that's okay we won't
achieve a little peace but right now
when he's done doing it right now
he called you 20 bucks and if you wanted
an English it cost you 40 okay my brain
is working hard
so the la puerta and the porta negra see
those can tackle me go see Sanada can be
a sailor for another brother is not
gonna be a person we're not at all
well it's a system be it a category
Kitana Champa okay este Pavo socket okay
Osito Chavez Catapano Sarada Contras
condado y rhema cha de la puerta negra
por que tous podraces tonsil osos y en
el miedo que yo te quiero de pensar que
estan Doan Sarada possibie car pronto
vacay a
pero la puerta nice en condado z-- van a
poder amid a tener me yak even our way
no pero la puerta no es la cool
get to put in through is this your Ando
to ami me Kira see yo te quiero la
puerta negra Sonny so Rondo
[Applause]
everybody Yuka
mmm they utilized a promo sassily series
Tolosa if you in solitude in a September
we've got a solid city every Saturday we
play in the Salt Lake Palace did you
know what it is
so the neighbor Rizal cause the black
door all right a porta negra
[Applause]
now I wanna say something else I think I
think it's very this is very good it's
only it's only fair for me to say that
everybody you know amigos inseparable
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
cuando el salvador pull intención de
Estados Unidos sevilla can SS atari
[Music]
entre las que tuvo que cruzar port is
undocumented dresses to wear yo la vie
de rigueur pour a sari Singh
[Applause]
what LaMichael Rinku under here for the
campus but I can clear my gustar say
yeah mom yo te Reagan Abba todo todo lo
que me Padilla's sin embargo Marek
llamas Sita bastami vida
pero to give me a sterile file says
promises they're more Barrow to game yes
battle gold personal chorus oh yeah
now we don't have excuse to uh from here
we went to a studio we're recording
right now and now we don't have an
excuse to be in the room warming up the
boys because we already were maps so
that that goes to a man because he
always gets later in studio because he
says that he's warming mapping his knack
is in the phone I hate I hate to be the
one interrupting this
[Applause]
just kidding just kidding whenever you
want to ask for people to leave the room
I'll start singing so in the meantime
let's let's give time for one last
question and I think there's a
microphone on the side so your music has
reflects a lot of the culture of Mexican
immigrants and I'm to some extent it
also encourages the culture as well or
kind of the culture reflects the music
and I was wondering to what extent do
you think your music has influenced um
you know like the business of drug use
or drug sales among Mexican immigrants
well we we sing these stories we're
seeing the the problems that we have is
a big problems like we discussed before
that I think of the impact is it can be
whoever it is is he we just put the
songs there and we talk about problems
that we that we leave and then it's
accept the person what road he wants to
take what way he wants to go he wants to
go right or left
the because we don't we only have the
opportunity to to expose what happened
for the story what happened with a
character like a movie you know what
exactly what happened but at the same
time we try to to give to the to the
strong character of the song to make it
to believe to do the best they go on the
good way and summon other traffickers or
whoever is involve in and out that kind
of business we only sing the stories and
and I hope when they listen these songs
and go for the right way those who don't
get their their other size we only the
other side the the
all these personalities that are
involved in contraband and all this they
only that their lives only have to two
ways to to enter up the pin they're up
in jail or ended up there that cementary
is only to waste you can take a look at
them this right we were supposed to
songs with we speak and the right way
for them so they can make a decision in
the future when they grow up and I said
decision that we have to take like every
decision that we have to make every day
where their own lives as a start-up we
make a proposition to them by putting
the song there an aged record that will
recall we have a story about the
community because we want to reflect
that and that most agreed on or they
have that opportunity the people to
believe what we sing and this is the way
we expose it to you that proposition
give it to you exactly so you can go in
the right way and I hope that personal
they listen to us go on the right way
unfortunately we're out of time but
please think we please please help me in
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you